Bonjour, Youtube propose un service qui s'appelle les sous-titres automatiques.
Ce service existe déjà depuis plusieurs années sur les vidéos anglaises
Et vient tout juste de sortir pour les vidéos françaises.
Le principe, Youtube scanne toutes les voix françaises d'une vidéo pour créer automatiquement les sous-titres.
C'est très pratique pour les gens qui apprennent le français
ou les malentendants.
Pour vous montrer le résultat je propose d'activer les sous-titres automatiques sur ma vidéo la plus vue
"Cyprien répond à Cortex" et de refaire les paroles en fonction des sous-titres. Ca donne ça :
♫ Nommé en mémoire toutes les cartes les plus élevés au monde. ♫
Bon, bah là il y'a un trou, ça commence bien...
Ça devait pas être très très important.
♫ C'est très bien. ♫
♫ Rappel points contre hanovre ♫
♫ Les basketteurs du tiroir-caisse ♫
♫ Mes collègues de viol sur Laëtitia ♫
♫ La légende pour exister et jeu ♫
♫ Cette entente  ♫
♫ Ayant toujours total, 19 8 euros ♫
♫ Dans sa lettre au capitaine de wolfsburg ♫
♫ Quand il était enfant doit s'exprimer vous étiez déjà majeur ♫
Encore un trou
Ceux qui apprenent le français se démerdent.
♫ Pour l'instant ♫
♫ Réagir a permettre carrière décolle pas d'impôts ♫
Et encore un trou, ça c'est pour les malentendants.
♫ On retourne à l'école,  jules-ferry d'anzin ♫
♫ Lisbonne pour ♫
♫ Il veut absolument me rancourt ♫
♫ Donné rendez-vous sur les choses ♫
♫ La cuvée 2007 des pickpockets ♫
♫ Tu fais partie des qualifiés ma petite idée en tête ♫
♫ Les dessins animé et leur est permise ♫
♫ La vie est une pilule contraceptive ♫
♫ En 2030 et le mensonge ♫
♫ J'ai ma grand-mère pour un bien ♫
♫ Un talent à cuba en étant reçus ♫
♫ Il est vrai qu'il est toujours officiellement le manoir ♫
Et pour finir, encore un petit trou.
♫ Ma mère m'a toujours à faire déplacer sur les handicaps ♫
( bruit de pistolet )
*éclaircissement de gorge*
Comme je le dis si bien,
"La vie est une pilule contraceptive".
Au revoir !
Tu veux voir mes prochaines vidéos ? Alors clique ici et abonne-toi à ma chaîne Youtube.
Sinon, retourne à l'école jules-ferry d'anzin.
Avec les basketteurs du tiroir-caisse.
Résultat : Les sous titres automatiques c'est carrément mieux que JuL. :')